Austin thank you so much for an
incredible weekend I love your comedy
scene down there Vancouver you are up
next September 15th through the 17th
Edmonton you're right after that
September 29th through October 1st
tickets to those shows and all shows are
available on my website at
ryansickler.com
[Music]
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media and again every week thank
you this channel this community
everything continues to grow and I can't
thank you enough for your support if
you're watching on YouTube please hit
that subscribe button help us get those
numbers up it's a free way to help the
show right and if you gotta have more
then you gotta check out the patreon the
patreon is the Honeydew with you all I'm
highlighting the low lights with you all
and these stories
I just look at the comments they're the
wildest [ __ ] you'll ever hear in your
life it is five dollars a month there's
no tears there's no level it's five
bucks a month if you're in for a year
you get over a month free you're getting
a honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost if you or someone you
know has that story that has to be heard
please submit it the Honeydew podcast
gmail.com and hopefully we get to do an
episode together now that's the biz guys
you guys know what we do over here we're
highlighting the low lights I always say
to you we're looking for a light in the
darkness these are the stories behind
the storytellers and ladies and
gentlemen I am very excited to have this
Storyteller here today with us for the
first time here on the do ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Eddie Pepito
welcome to the Honeydew Eddie thank you
everybody it feels really good to be
here I'm a Storyteller I I I I you know
they say that storytellers aren't
happening anymore like we used to as a
culture when we first started right and
I'm talking about before the Greeks you
know uh we would just tell stories
around a fire
and now people text
you know they text each other and you
really can't tell good stories man
people need to get together more please
get together more and tell each other's
stories well let's tell some today but
before we do I don't want to get too far
into a please promote plug everything
you would like uh you know folks already
you could tell I'm funny
um
eddiepepitone.com is the mothership
eddiepepitone.com
all my dates I am going to be uh in
Chicago on the 15th at the Lincoln Lodge
I'm gonna be at good nights in Raleigh
on the 16th I am going to be in Richmond
Virginia on the 17th by the way I only
go one night okay I'm in and out I have
the law on me I have to keep moving and
I go by an alias which is Eddie Pepito
my real name is Melvin schmidnik I'll be
at the idiot idiot box the 19th I'll be
uh idiot box to 20 20th I'll be making
Georgia August 25th Atlanta Georgia the
26th and on and on so uh
eddiepepitone.com and you can see me
there in my social media Instagram at
eddiepep Twitter at eddiepapitone and
that's it all right thank you thank you
Melvin
um don't mention that name all right I
you're an interesting person you're an
interesting character you're always the
guy that you can count on to break the
[ __ ] tension in the room to drop the
jokes to to make people laugh never take
it too seriously I love that about you
um but I do want to get to know you
better so yeah how old are you now Eddie
63 all right you're 63. you know I lie I
lie because of Hollywood I'm really 79.
by the way you know in Hollywood you're
supposed to you know lie like say like
if you're 63 you're supposed to say I'm
56 right I could maybe get away maybe
but I lie up like I I when I meet with
people and I pitch things like oh I'm
79. they're like wow you look good
that's how you have to play This Town
all right whale's so old though 63. yeah
where are you originally from where are
you born and raised I was born in
Brooklyn in a little town called
Brooklyn and
um I was there for nine years uh and my
dad finally bought us a house when I was
nine years old and we moved to the quote
unquote country Staten Island oh yeah
all the way out there okay
which you know when I was a little kid
it did seem like the country because uh
Brooklyn was so congested and
everybody's on top of each other you
know and uh in Staten Island there were
woods around me we were one of the only
houses on the Block right now my dad's
house he still lives in the same house
is is just inundated
my dad is 90. wow all right he won't die
which sucks because I get the house when
he dies Dad if you're listening please
die
I don't want to go you heard those dates
who wants to go to Greensboro
you know what I mean you know what I
mean
Ryan and
and your audience he it's like he's not
even having fun anymore you know what I
mean when you hit 90 you basically being
dragged around by helpers like here
let's go here and it's like what kind of
fun is that and your mom's gone my mom
did die yeah she died during one of my
sets
it wasn't going well and she couldn't
take it you know I was getting heckled
by my father
no uh yeah my my mom did pass away
um
I think it was something like 15 years
ago and and it was [ __ ] up because she
died alone and I wanted to be with her
but I was watching the Giants and they
were driving they were driving it was a
playoff game it was Green Bay and I
couldn't they said you got to get to the
hospital right away it was like the
Giants are on the eight yards the Giants
are on the eight yards
all right let's go back I think I've
alienated a lot of people already
because I'm so dark about my family
because it was painful well that's what
this Show's all about that's exactly
what it's about so Dad moves you guys
out to Staten Island who's you guys or
mom and dad still together at that time
yes and you have siblings mom and dad
and my sweet sister Susan okay just the
two of you guys just the two of us all
right you know and who's older I am
three years older than my sister all
right so at age what'd you say by eight
nine you guys moved I was nine yeah yeah
and that was uh what grade I always go
by grades that was like fourth I was
gonna say fourth grade fourth grade okay
so what um what's life like there you
say it was painful what what starts to
happen well this is gonna get a little
heavy but my mom uh was bipolar and this
is before you know medication stuff she
had a electroshock you know she had she
was in in and out of hospital so it was
dark my dad was you know he was kind of
a rageaholic you know and my mom was
going in and out Institute so you can
imagine I just escaped into man I just
escaped into two things weed when I was
14
and just planned tons of Sports One
Thing Staten Island was good for not
good for many things if you're a reader
don't go to Staten Island people don't
read books they communicate by hitting
each other with baseball bats but
I would I love hockey and there was a
there was the woods and ponds and I
would play hockey you know uh and it was
amazing and my dad would play too he was
a good hockey player growing up he
played roller hockey in Brooklyn on the
streets damn but he was a good skater
too but he tore his ligaments I remember
knee ligaments while we were playing and
he was down for a long time I remember
yeah I was like get up
we're not stopping
ligaments can be just ice it no so yeah
so back then you say your mom's bipolar
was it diagnosed back then as bipolar
and they just don't know what to do with
it so they're treating her with
different uh yeah methods medications
that sort of thing you said shock
therapy was one of those you had some
electro shock which I believe they still
do you know I do it every time I try to
plug in my toaster I have a [ __ ] up
however
folks if you have a [ __ ] [ __ ] up
toaster you may be able to heal yourself
through electric shock no but yeah and
medications but I don't think they were
as good as the medications today if
today what sort of relationships like
gummy bears are terrific what sort of
relationship did you have whether were
you able to have one not real you know I
loved her of course but it was it was
not great because my mom would go
really bipolar like like hallucinations
on the
on the um mannequins you know they
called it manic depression back then
okay
and then on the depressed man she would
she would be bedridden for for a long
time like and I'd be pissed I'd be like
I wanted [ __ ] attention you know
which is now why I seek you're getting a
little sense of like why I'm a comedian
because I didn't get that Mom love
so I'm all about like I Wanna Be Loved
You know and that's why I drive a Honda
Element it's a night
by the way shouldn't commercials be like
that like you give a story about your
mother having Electric Shot
and it ends that's why I drive behind
the element
because there's room to weep in that car
it's boxy it's good
oh my God what's your relationship like
with your dad do you stay away from you
say he's a rageaholic are you scared of
him oh my God I I you know also I mean
how do you not love your [ __ ] family
right but it's fraught with [ __ ] and he
is he is a [ __ ] pill do you know what
I mean he's 90 and you're supposed to
mellow
at 90. but he really he really hasn't we
still have things you know he's become a
lot more supportive me when I first told
my dad that I was going into comedy he
wanted me to be a doctor you know and I
was like I remember walking into the
bedroom and saying to him dad and I'll
never forget
um I'm gonna study acting I'm dropping
out of I was going to Fordham University
I was trying to please him to be a great
school be a dentist and my teeth I
should have been
just to get my own teeth worked on I
probably would have Dent his friends
I don't know if dentists can work on
them
imagine me working on my
mom and I'm talking to myself going now
Eddie you raise your hand when it hurts
but um so you go to tell them huh I told
him that I'm I'm gonna go into acting
because I and and acting
you know I love doing acting in
Manhattan and but every [ __ ] scene
that I did people would laugh like I'd
be doing Death of a Salesman and people
would be laughing so I knew comedy was
my Landing place you know and comedy was
a way that I [ __ ] got out my [ __ ] you
know like uh I would make my friends
laugh insanely and I was hooked
from about I think I started making my
friends left like when I was when I
moved to Staten Island you know because
it was nothing really to do on Staten
Island you know this still isn't but I
would um you know we'd be standing
around smoking pot and I would just go
into characters and and they'd be like
oh [ __ ] it he's funny you know I love
that
so what point then do you head to the
city to pursue this okay and can I ask
one more question sorry Fordham is a
good school it's not cheap is Dad paying
for this yeah extra disappointed yes all
right yes he didn't want to pay for it
you know he was all about me getting
grants and I'm like look I don't know
how to get a grant
is it not easy no they're not they had a
little more money I think for students
back then but anyway I I defaulted on my
my student loan year they don't even go
after me anymore because I just when I
get letters from Banks I just threaten
them like I just say I will drive around
your bank until you [ __ ] let that
loan go you know because I'm good with
Molotov well anyway mom and cough
cocktails anyway you go to my website
show how to make them uh
the Mothership
the Mothership
I like that uh but yeah so what was the
question the question is you moving to
New York after you've told your dad is
that the next step you leaving Fordham
and going to Manhattan to pursue comedy
yes yes uh I went to school I always was
still a city kid thank God because
Staten Island was seriously like
Deliverance back then it's more hip now
I think but back then man it was like
you know what I mean it was very uh
rural kinda and um so I went to Brooklyn
Tech High School and Brooke so I would
travel I was traveling like a coal miner
when I was 14 I lived right next door to
a high school Tottenville but instead my
father wanted me to go to Brooklyn Tech
first of all I'm not a tech tech person
in chemistry lab I would just [ __ ] up
experiments like I was terrible but I
traveled I would get up it would be dark
I'd be going to Brooklyn Tech
um but that kept me in the city because
I was going through Manhattan to get to
Brooklyn and I always hung out there you
know what and and a lot of times I would
just hang in the village at Washington
Square Park Park became my favorite
place I would smoke weed and listen to
musicians and there was a comic I don't
know if you remember this guy black
comic named Charlie Barnett who used to
perform you know in Washington Square
and he was good man the name does sound
familiar yeah I can't say that yeah he
actually was on SNL for a heartbeat and
I forget what happened but Charlie was
great and died of AIDS back then but
um you know so I was a Manhattan guy uh
Brooklyn guy even though I lived in
Staten Island and then I started
studying and acting yeah and in
Manhattan and I my
my one of my first Apartments was near
the ferry like I I I moved out in steps
and it was my first apartment and this
is one of the stories I want to tell you
so my first apartment the only thing I
can afford you know was
room
with a shared
bathroom Jack and Jill bathroom is that
what they call I learned on this show
because I have one too in a place and I
didn't know what it's called yeah I
don't even like that never even saw the
dude on the other side okay
so this place yeah I had a room and
there was upstairs and there was a room
up there and the guy who lived upstairs
I never saw him but I heard him he was
like the [ __ ] Joker he was I come to
realize a meth addict back then you know
that was like 19 what
76 something like that 70 yeah the
[ __ ] guy would yeah he would just be
upset I would hear him running giggling
and I'd be in my little room I had a hot
plate you know I had a hot plate and I
would be like making just the worst kind
of [ __ ] food and I'd be getting high
and I'd hear this lunatic and I remember
I I I had a this was wild I had this
girlfriend who was who was actually my
friend had just broke up with this girl
and he was Furious
at me that I was dating her but I I
didn't care she was very pretty and
um you know she would be she was in my
room one time and we're getting it on
and I hear this guy up he must hear it
the walls were not good and he would he
hurt us getting it on and he was like
the [ __ ] it like it was
insane and to my girlfriend's credit at
the time she was she kept going you know
she was like hearing this lunatic I mean
it was a lunatic but not only that but
her boyfriend
was stalking me for a bit and he knew I
was with her
at that time and he was knocking I got
the guy upstairs
screaming hilarious and this guy his
name was Spencer I don't remember his
last name Spencer if you're listening
nothing ever happened
[Laughter]
we had oral sex Spencer but
how great is how you know anyway it was
never intercourse
um but um he was knocking at the window
my window my front window he was
knocking at it and she knew it was him
and she was like she just froze up and I
froze up to it I want to deal with this
[ __ ] guy he scared me he was older
you know and I got this lunatic upstairs
and him him knocking on the window and
he finally went away and we did that
thing where we just we just played dad
for a long time you know
but that apartment was so [ __ ] nuts I
remember when I had to leave I had mice
in that appointment
mice and I'll never forget and of course
I was always I was always stoned back
then I'll never forget
um one point I was at the I was just
sitting on my bed and I looked down and
me and this mouse
made eye contact he had a moment with
them I had a moment with The Mouse and
the mouse
I guess saw me you know it's when the
mouse saw me it jumped straight in the
air to eye level and I said I have to
get out of this place
the meth addict
getting stalked
this little mouse coming up
and I got an apartment in Queens finally
so we talked before the show about you
said you suffer do you still suffer but
you did panic attack I'm on medication
that really helps it uh Zoloft okay is
designed to it's designed hit anxiety so
go back to when this first started when
did you and how did you even know what
it was awesome are you freaking out like
oh my God I have my mom [ __ ] yes you
know yes
yes that was definitely it I was like
holy [ __ ] what age does this sort of hit
you about 59 no
[Laughter]
no
this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] was so [ __ ] scary I would
say I was in my
20s about I can't I are you good with
dates like when this happened you know
what's funny my past yes last few years
especially what you know
the weed has gotten better yeah
um so I would say in my 20s and
it was like it first started manifesting
like I would just I'd just be like this
I'd be like
oh boy I
I it would come over me man like so
scary it would feel like a shroud or
another Bean kinda taking over your body
like and it would be in my chest it
would just be it really was kind of a
monster like now I'm able able to
visualize it back then I just felt it in
my throat in my chest and what would
happen is that I'd be you know I in
particular places it would manifest and
I realized it was some kind of
claustrophobia at first like I'd be on a
subway a New York City subway scary
enough right but then I'd be on the
subway and all of a sudden
I'd be like I'd start to get nervous and
that nervousness went to a level
where I was just like oh my God I
can't uh I can't breathe and I would do
[ __ ] like um I would turn to the person
next to me on the subway check this out
I would go could you talk I would go can
you talk to me for a second I'm having
trouble and that person whether a man or
a woman would just get up and leave
probably wouldn't even say it and I even
did it on the street to somebody I was
having a panic attack on the street and
I remember that one was brought on it'd
be sometimes it'd be brought on by
partying too much like like I'd just be
shaky from a night out and I remember I
was walking down the streets of
Manhattan and I turned to a woman I go
okay can you uh just talk to me for like
a CO you know a minute I'm having and
she I never I'll remember just the way
she backed away you know I was like Wow
people get scared when you say stuff
like that like out of the box like can
you just talk to me I need help that's
kind of yeah that's kind of that's kind
of a horror movie thing can you just
talk or really set I mean if it's
Saturday too
if it's set in a diner it's it's sad if
it's sad in the subway
[Laughter]
that is true I'll never forget
I'll never forget to have the panic
attacks would manifest I remember one
time I was bike messengering in
Manhattan I want to hear about this well
that was a crazy period for me too
because just picture bike messengering
like down fifth [ __ ] Avenue Seventh
Avenue it's just so crowded so insane
and back then there were tons of bike
Messengers on the streets there were no
bike Lanes I don't think yet or maybe
there were the whole was it Quicksilver
with Kevin Bacon I think it was a whole
movie
I was up for you know because I was hot
back then I I had I was exercising like
crazy you know I had a lot of work done
back then it is falling now
and the dermatologist told me this will
last you you know up until you're 61.
no but I remember one time delivering I
would go it was hilarious because I was
the work by worst bike messenger in the
world meaning I would do I would do a
couple of runs he was supposed to work
like they would want to get you to work
from like nine to like six at night and
if they sent me into the village
I'd be like that's it for me and I just
wind up in Washington Square Park
hanging out with musicians or whatever
and I didn't care about money I was like
who gives a [ __ ] you know our first
sponsor is prize picks for kickoff I've
got Josh Allen throwing for more than
250 yards I got my man Lamar Jackson
rushing for more than 75 yards and
Cooper cup is going to score more than
.5 touchdowns prize picks format is
simple it's easy to understand so even
if you aren't a football fanatic you can
still play you pick two to five players
and if they score more or less than
their prize picks projection you can win
up to 10 times your money on any entry
no competing against other people it's
just you versus the projections
available and there are projections for
any sport you watch NFL NBA mob NHL PGA
college football men's college
basketball women's college basketball
soccer WNBA Esports NASCAR tennis MMA
boxing disc golf Euro basketball cricket
and more it's out there worldwide
entries can be made in 60 seconds or
less they're safe and fast withdrawal
and currently operational in over 30
States and Canada download the prize
picks app or go to prize picks.com to
sign up and play daily fantasy sports
first time users can receive a 100
instant deposit match up to 100 with
promo code honeydew if you deposit one
hundred dollars prize picks will give
you 100 if you deposit 50 prize pick
will give you 50. don't forget to enter
the promo code honeydew at sign up for
an instant deposit match up to one
hundred dollars lately I've been
listening to a lot of two bears one cave
and where my mom's at and it's been
awesome one reason it's been so awesome
because I use my Raycom wireless earbuds
to do it raycons everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me raycons give you eight hours of
play time in a 32 hour battery life
raycons are priced just right you get
quality audio and half the price of
other premium audio Brands let me say
this I use the other brands and I use my
raycons all the time and I'm telling you
the raycons are money you could take
calls on them the the conversations are
super clear I've had no problems with
them
I'm just telling you they're fantastic
especially on places like a loud plane
or something I have no problem hearing
or listening to anything that I want to
hear all right so go to buy raycon.com
honeydew today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon.com honeydew to
score 15 off by raycon.com honeydew guys
Babble is back and I couldn't be more
excited you know Spanish I've talked
about it here I'm taking Spanish and
it's something I wish I took more I took
it in like eighth grade and then 9th
10th and 11th and I I struggle with
English there was no way I got a d in
Spanish like one of my only D's in high
school ever so if you're like me and
there's a foreign language that you
regret not learning in school it's never
too late to start with Babble Babble is
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions thanks to
Babel's fun and easy bite-sized language
lessons you can finally cross learning
that new language off your list I told
you I'm taking Spanish and the way they
do it they break it down you're gonna
read it you're gonna hear it you're
gonna also repeat it back all right you
gotta sit there and work on your accent
and everything in Babel is great about
that all right you only need 10 minutes
to complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans but Babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
and with Babel you can choose from 14
different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German plus Babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with Babel in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts Games videos stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee so start
your new language learning Journey today
with Babel right now get up to 55 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com honeydew that's babel.com
honeydew for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for life
now let's get back to the do
but anyway I remember I would go into
these corporations in Midtown Manhattan
you know just looking like [ __ ] you know
and and these people were so well
dressed to be going to law firms you
know whatever in Manhattan you know the
big [ __ ] corporate stuff and I remember
one time I started getting a panicky
thinking I went into their bathroom I
said can I use your bathroom they gave
me their key and you know there's a
couple of execs in there and I started
getting hives that's another way Panic
where anxiety can manifest I had these
you and I'm I'm like I get paranoid if I
see anything on my body you know whether
I see a little black mark you know on my
body I'm like what the [ __ ] is that or
if I just see you know uh uh someone who
works in sales on my body whoever
but these were huge welts hives I don't
know if you've ever had them not from
anxiety though
oh like getting bit by something a bite
a rash something like that but I'm right
this friend of mine that would throw up
all the time before games and he would
break out like it would look almost like
freckles across his face the hives would
come out across his face and he had to
go sideline for a minute and then he'd
come back out every game oh my God I
learned that the way to get rid of it
with antihistamines oh yeah we'd [ __ ]
get rid of it like that the hives and I
had to go because that's when AIDS was
just first happening and one of the
symptoms of AIDS was Hive so I remember
I I had to go to the doctor now I had
never had sex with a man I was always
rebuffed so
you know I would plead you know I
couldn't even get a glory hole thing you
know what I mean the glory hole they
were like no thank you like they would
just yell through the plywood or the
Plexiglas they would be no thank you and
I'd be like please somebody touch me
just hug my dick
[Laughter]
ah so
um anyway I had to get I I was scared my
doctor was like oh this is a symptom of
AIDS and he worked in Chelsea where he
was dealing with a lot of HP so I didn't
have it obviously but it was scary I I
just went through this whole period I
would say it lasted these and you never
knew I never knew when they went because
they say they were unpredictable you
weren't like all this is gonna happen
now I didn't get on a subway for a while
I'm or an elevator all of a sudden I
couldn't take elevators and to me that
meant claustrophobia like like elevator
can't get out Subway I would you know
when I would start to panic on a subway
um when
the Subways would stop in between
stations and say there's another train
ahead of us just a little delay
and I would be like
okay you know and it would slowly come
on will you is there anybody to talk
with there you'd have the whole car to
yourself
what about and I'd start conversation
like what about the weather huh this
system doesn't seem like it's going to
move
um how are you on flights that's even
smaller than a Subway
um yeah I I don't think I flew that much
back then I would be driving you know
like I would just drive you can open a
window in a car you could feel better
[ __ ] like that control I think it was
the lack of control I feel like and the
trapped element like ah it was scary so
how did you start the work on it and
beat it well I was in therapy and I and
I wasn't on any medication okay and
finally my shrink was like you know what
Eddie you have suffered enough with this
because I didn't want to go on
medication because my mom was always on
medications and back then I was like nah
medications are gonna numb you you know
I won't be as funny blah blah blah I was
the same word same worry like yeah is
this gonna change who I am like a God
forbid I'm such I'm so well funnier I'm
so well put together if I'm not on a
train or an elevator
uh so she put me with a psychiatrist who
referred me to a psychiatrist the
dispenser of the meds and they put me on
a combination back then it was Prozac
and
um Klonopin and I'll tell you the
Klonopin
really knocked out that anxiety did it
uh oh yeah and not only that but it's
very addictive you know and I I got off
Klonopin because I was always like I was
always like doing this [ __ ] like I
wasn't anxious but I'd be but the
Klonopin was such a nice mellow feeling
that I would go I think I am a little
anxious
I wouldn't be but I'd be convincing
myself you know I probably could use a
half
and so that was a slippery slope you
know what I mean but you were able to
beat you fly now you'd ever you're good
on all this stuff do you ever have panic
attacks anymore you know what they are
rare good they are very rare and I
realize when I'm susceptible to them and
that is when I'm extremely tired
when I am tired and haven't slept
stressed about where like getting to
gigs you know playing an early early
flight I have to be be careful because
in early flight like if I have to go to
LAX
and every plane at LAX feels like the
last plane out of Saigon to me which is
which is why I like the Burbank Airport
I don't know if you know the Burbank oh
it is so sweet you know it's like going
to Andy Griffith's Mayberry Town hi
there Bob but um actually TSA Pre helps
so much oral and clear I'm on both of
them through that [ __ ] if they have it
yeah yeah I never did the clear thing I
don't but the TSA Pre is amazing and I
usually don't tell anybody about it
because it's [ __ ] great and I don't
want anybody else getting it
um anyway uh yeah so I'm I'm I'm okay
now but I have to be careful man if I
haven't
slept you know but you know I realized
too that all of this anxiety that I was
experiencing then was this accumulation
yeah tell me about it yeah this
accumulation
of I don't know self-loathing like
unexpressed
feelings uh you know like you know being
traumatized by my dad's rage by you know
my mom's depression that kind of thing
and I never really got it out and I
think what happened is that it turned on
me like uh all of this stuff turned on
me and I think when I really started
doing my comedy and committing I started
Living my own life like I was kind of
living for my dad and what he and I
still have this problem of trying to
please every [ __ ] body around people
pleaser yeah yeah I think a lot of
comics have that
um
and now I kind of go the other way where
I just insult audiences
[ __ ] funny you know hopefully a funny
way where I'm go where I say I don't
respect you people
I just did 30 minutes and it was easy
I thought there would be pushback in
Lincoln Nebraska
you're soft
so uh I think it really had a lot to do
with me living in inauthentic life like
trying to please [ __ ] everybody I had
no idea who I was and one of the ways
this [ __ ] anxiety manifested I would
check this out this was scary I would
look in a mirror
and I would not and I'm being serious
recognize who I was looking at and I'd
have to run out of the [ __ ] mirror
run away from the mirror because I
didn't know who I it was like a literal
you know I didn't know who I was and now
I can't get enough of myself in a mirror
you ever look into your eyes and want to
[ __ ] yourself like
I and I have beautiful I have blue eyes
and I lose myself I lose myself with my
eyes now in a mirror and I just jerkle I
I jerk off and the fantasy is me taking
me out to dinner
[ __ ] me in the bathroom I would
imagine also beyond [ __ ] in the
bathroom that now too if these panic
attacks do come on you know what's going
on it's not a foreign feeling to like
that very first few times like what the
[ __ ] is this now you've got an edge it's
still scary though I imagine I'm saying
at least the the unknown is not there
about it anymore right you're like is
this a heart attack am I what am I happy
you know what though about that because
I I I'd always thought I would die you
know from the feeling of that like it
would kill you yes yes
and and the doctors talk about this [ __ ]
it mirrors heart attacks you know but
it's not you know and a lot of people go
to emergency rooms which I did a couple
of times just wander into an emergency
room in Manhattan you know and uh you
know 600 later being told yeah you're
fine they would give me an anti-anxiety
thing and now I carry around instead of
Klonopins called Ativan which is I tell
you as far as a drug uh that Mellows you
it's not like Klonopin which was a
beautiful nice trip this is more like
yeah the anxiety's gone but I don't feel
like
doing anything with it
you know you would yeah yeah Klonopin I
would be like
[Music]
you know I'd be like I'd be like sort of
like I'm glad I had a panic attack it
would be wild with clown opinion you
know because you would go from this
intense panic
to this
incredible relaxation and you you almost
look back at the panic attack and go
what the [ __ ] happened there
you know
like why you know because it's too such
uh disparate frames of mind it's like so
different you know and and it's amazing
it just makes me think how we're we are
brain chemistry it I mean it's amazing
how bills just change I'm sitting here
thinking about it because I was so
against pills for so long too medication
medication I'm already on cholesterol
blood you know yeah yeah I go to the
doctor every six months I do my I do I
get a full lipid panel urine all that
[ __ ] done urine
make sure it's not [ __ ] with my
kidneys you know because they found out
a lot of Roundup in my urine I just saw
that I just saw that today I'm like
[ __ ] around them goddamn piss so
I'm gonna just hire myself out as a crop
duster
it's from Australia underneath
the plane and drink the water
beer and water
yeah
but I did I started taking it was during
the pandemic when they told us we had to
homeschool
my kid you know my kid wasn't a teenager
my daughter my stepson was he's fine my
daughter's five she's just learned how
to read so I'm sitting there with her
and we're doing these lessons together
and I'm I can't
what are you talking about I'm stuck in
this box now and and my job my creative
Outlet the only thing that has saved me
from all this [ __ ] over these years
now we can't even do stand-ups gone yeah
so it was luck Zoom stand up yeah that
was a dream I never did it and it was
lean into this and I got on some
medication I started taking because
Christina P she's told me 10 milligrams
Alexa Pro and it worked for her I'm not
a drinker so I don't have to worry about
mixing it with alcohol or anything like
that good
um because I know there's problems with
that kind of stuff but um right so just
so that was 10 milligrams and you're
good yeah it's helped I mean I don't
know I don't know what 20 would do you
know what I mean I've only tried 10 but
I um I was very you know that machismo
way of a lot of guys I don't need their
totally I was all about therapy and all
mental health but it was something about
the hill I know that felt like you feel
like cheating yeah or I'm not a man
right right you know yeah I need this
crutch to I I'm not a complete person I
and then I and then I started taking
that pill I was like [ __ ] that dumb way
of thinking I don't have anxiety about
that anymore that's right yeah and and
you realize it doesn't take away your
creativity at all and I'm so glad you
said that because that's the first thing
I thought is this gonna change my fiber
is this gonna change who I am and it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't it just
kind of takes the edge off yeah it just
kind of levels you to a point
um and I'm not saying take Lexapro I
mean every yeah every person
[Laughter]
everyone's chemical makeup is different
it was so law off work for you it might
be the worst thing for me oh yeah
consult your goddamn no I can get you
Zola
you meet me at a 7-Eleven in the valley
all right no
um
I wanted to say about the milligrams my
doctor started me on 50 milligrams of
Zoloft I'm on 200 now all right and and
that's the level that works for me and I
remember I what I do is uh I have a joke
where I go I'm on two hunt to the crowd
I go I'm on 200 milligrams of Zoloft and
it does nothing for me I just like the
taste
I crush it in a mortar and pestle and I
pour it on cereal and I watch porn muted
I don't even masturbate I just eat my
soul though actually one of the shows I
did I there was a nurse in the audience
and I said I'm on 200 milligrams of
Zoloft and she went Jesus
and
and I said what and I found that she's a
nurse I go really is that high she goes
yes and I go well that's what my shrink
wants me on I got mad at her
um all right I want to shift gears to
this other story because I you have a
very interesting story about a
relationship you may have talked about
this way back when on your crab feast
episode I I don't know I don't maybe but
I want to hear this so when at the age
of 20 you dated a woman who was
uh 40 40 20 years you're senior now she
seduced me I mean I was a nervous kid
you know
um had you lost your virginity or is
this your virginity to this woman uh
[ __ ] I I had lost it but then I found it
found it again for another five years so
I lost it again actually I think she was
the first person really that I actually
had intercourse with uh because real
quick you're 20. how old's your mom at
the time well you're 20. my mom was 18.
I was 20. it was the weirdest [ __ ] I
she had the Aging disease where she was
going backwards no uh my mom how was
your mom when she had you
yeah that's a good [ __ ] question
um I think she was like 21. so This
Woman's about the age of your mom so you
figure it out anywhere we go but I was
very attracted to her she was a history
teacher
um and where at College High School
College at Fordham no it was uh I had
dropped out of Fordham and went to the
College of Staten Island which actually
had great professors from Manhattan she
was great just total intellectual and I
was always into leftist politics I loved
Karl Marx Das Capital all this [ __ ] and
she was an activist and attractive and
I'd just be in a class like oh my
and uh I would go up to it after class
and say things like um you know
I'm having trouble
understanding the feudal system
you know and one time I asked her a
question like that after class and she
said well
because I didn't know she was into me
either she goes well why don't you come
over my apartment and we'll go over it
and that's so naive that I thought this
is very nice of her
really you were really thinking that you
weren't thinking I'm gonna get laid no
okay so I go to her apartment in
Greenwich Village and to me it was the
coolest [ __ ] thing in the world you
know
and um we're sitting we're laying on her
rug reading daw's capital what's she
wearing
she was just dressed she wasn't yeah
there wasn't so when you got there there
still wasn't an indication for you like
right she was being cool okay
and uh but she turns to me as we're
reading this and she goes do you smoke
pot
and I'm like yes and as soon as I got
high
I we just started kissing and so it was
on from there it was on from there but
what was really hard for me like I was
ecstatic because I was like I can't
believe that this woman likes me was
that she spoke six languages was so
experienced in different Affairs around
the world I was so in love with her that
I was like the little girl in the
relationship yeah
campus like she was like don't hold
don't [ __ ] do that on campus you know
and I'd be like why I was you know I was
just like clingy and not only that but
then we would hang out with some of her
friends who were these people all had
phds all spoke different languages and
they would be talking about [ __ ] so far
over my head you know the you know the
revolution in Yugoslavia uh you know
this artist that artist and they turned
to me Eddie what do you think and I'd be
like well the Yankees are having a good
year
yeah I got nothing guys oh dude it made
me I was always into reading books and
[ __ ] I was always
kind of geared toward being an
intellectual sort of and it made me like
read all the I got exposed to a lot of
good [ __ ] but it was so painful not
being able to socialize with these
people and I felt like I was a object in
a museum to them they'd be like huh I
think he'll be an art I remember one of
them said I think he'll be an artist
like it I'm just going
just this piece of clay sitting over
there yeah waiting to be molded yeah but
uh yeah I was with her on and off I was
gonna ask how long six years wow
man yeah for six years uh it was it was
it was it was fraught it was my friend I
mean you could imagine coming from you
know my background I was just like
jealous you know she had an ex who was
kind of in a she also had a little
daughter
uh who was so [ __ ] sweet and I would
tell her story I don't know if you do
this with your daughter but I would I
would make up stories I would go okay
her name is Sasha her name is Sasha and
I would go okay so there was this girl
her name was Sasha and she would just
light up right I forget how old she was
in three four and uh I would tell this
story about her and then at the end of
the story she would go do it again yeah
do you yeah and then I'm like [ __ ] I
can't remember what I said I just told
you I made up five minute story yeah
yeah do it again and I would just tell
another story you know and by the third
story be like look
I have [ __ ] to do
come on hurry all right you get your ass
to bed what a sweet kid though
but I fought with Manuela a lot her name
is Manuela uh she died recently she
really did yeah oh man what happened uh
she had like like a terrible Gastro and
as something or other you know I didn't
really I hadn't been in contact with her
a lot we we did see each other now she's
20 years older right we saw each other a
few years back and then I and I was
looking at her going she doesn't look
that great at 77.
because I was thinking of hitting it
again
and I was like no no
you know I'm not doing because we were
hiking she was a big hiker you know and
I was thinking of driving her into the
bushes
but yeah regular [ __ ] hips
[Laughter]
um
what do you take from that relationship
it's a 20 it's a woman who's 20 years
older than you you know do you have you
ever dated an age Gap like that again
no no no no you're married right I am
married yeah how long have you been
married I've been married 10 years and
before that we dated seven
so it's a long time a long time yeah my
wife is like 10 years younger than me
you know which in Hollywood isn't cool
you should be dating someone 30 years
yeah
and I'm available no uh
um
but I never I never did you know it
would be funny if I if I still had the
older lady thing and like I'm 63 and I
always and I would just Cruise nursing
homes like looking for an 83 year old
they would love somebody Papa town bro
how you doing did you did you did you
watch my special like I told you like I
told you I don't understand your anger
come on society's falling apart
um do you have any kids no no I knew not
to have children why because I was first
of all and and I really kind of applaud
the comics and there's a lot of them who
bring up kids and to me that's a huge
financial uh
stress
you know because what we do I think is
very [ __ ] uh it's not that reliable
it's scary it's [ __ ] Hollywood and uh
performing you know the income I didn't
really start making money in this
business until I was like
40 something you know what I mean that's
when you start to see A change is in
your 40s it really is yeah it's great
it's a long [ __ ] time to be most
people give it up yeah by then or die
they usually blow their brains out in a
hotel in Greensboro
20 there again what are the ticket sales
you're [ __ ] kidding me they've sold
eight tickets
but um yeah so so it was a conscious
decision versus not uh being able to
well you know it was it was conscious
and also my background I I just had so
much anxiety you know I'm sure everybody
has this about bringing the kid up wrong
you know and I'm amaz and especially now
with what's going on now in our world
and especially in this country with guns
I mean you tell me I mean I wouldn't be
I would be so overprotective I'm so like
codependent that if I had a little kid a
girl
you have a girl yeah little girl now
what do you you must work do you or you
can I do yeah you can't I mean a good
parent will forever you know your your
job as a parent does install yours did
but you're my mind did too but yours
your job as a parent shouldn't stop let
me say that doesn't shouldn't stop
yeah
so yeah yeah and and then the and then
the anxiety changes to all right now
they're driving all right well now they
live on their own all right now they're
married all right now they have you know
what I mean like it's a it's a
never-ending cycle of introduction
introducing new Stress and Anxiety
flexapro 10 might be good
if you have nieces nephews do you have
any you do yeah yeah yeah yeah
um nephews nieces uh that's cousins
right
yeah
yeah you know we were kind of a tight
knit group when we were living in
Brooklyn you know when I used to hang
out with with
um you know my cousins all the time and
we would hang and stuff but then we all
moved they moved to Long Island which my
father would say [ __ ] Ambi has to
move to Long Island it's an hour and a
half to get there he hated it my my
uncle Ambi moved to Shoreham Long Island
which is where they built a nuclear
power plant he lives next to a nuclear
power they shut it down but not a good
move yeah
but yeah yeah but I I don't see them
much anymore
but it's funny because they see me you
know doing the comedy thing you know
yeah so you go for people who don't know
you you I mean you've to just throw out
some of your roles from Old School I
mean you've been in so many films it's a
great one well the first thing that
really kind of got me I didn't have you
know got me work a bunch was Conan I
knew one and this is how I've gotten
most of my work by the way I know the
writers on these [ __ ] shows and
they're like oh pepper tone would be
good because auditioning for things is
not easy and most [ __ ] directors or
shows have people in mind they know they
[ __ ] want and it ain't you yeah you
know what I mean so
um but I was I was I I waited a lot of
tables in New York and I was the world's
worst waiter you know I just they they I
I and I had friends who would get me
jobs and and in high-end restaurants and
my shirt always had little chocolate
spots on it from the desserts I would
eat in the stairwell
I used to eat something called
profiteroles which are puff pastries
with ice cream and chocolate syrup in
this that sounds good it's [ __ ]
delicious and so I would you know I'd be
eating that [ __ ] in the stairwell
chocolate and have to go to a table I
remember my manager she was a woman and
she just looked at me uh when I was on
the uh you know waiting on a table with
chocolate and she couldn't help herself
in front of customer she's just looking
at my shirt that was still freshly
dripping because I had to rent run out
and she goes really
really
and she fired me that that day you know
and I became a barber for a while no I
was here how funny would that be
uh but yeah
I got a call
I mean I have been working here and
there but I got a call to be on Conan
and it was a monologue
uh that they wanted me to do about being
the guy who got passed over as the Life
cereal kid okay because that was Mikey
Mikey Elite it and this bit was I and I
had to do this to the camera I was
grounded
when the life people were coming around
and I did it like that you know I was
grounded this kid Mikey he sucked I
should have been a Life kid and I it was
a rant and I ended it by uh throwing the
box of life on the ground and stomping
on and it was a huge moment for me
because I was in front of a live
audience in Rock Center you know where
Conan when he was in New York used to
tape and he just kept using me you know
I became I don't know if he ever saw
this but I for years on Conan I would be
the Heckler who would Heckle him and it
was a great bit like I was really
featured you know and then you hit films
after that I had some film work it moved
old school the movie with Will Ferrell
Vince Vaughn Luke Wilson who I became
little buddies with at that point
um
they they FL you know I came to LA to
film it I had never been and uh they is
that right yeah just coming out to do
old school was the first time you'd even
been to California never done comedy
here before or anything oh wow no no no
no no no no no no no and uh they put me
up in an apartment in Venice by the
ocean and I was like this is [ __ ]
great and I had a manager who was based
in LA and she was like look you should
come here there's more work here like
she was like you know making the case
for LA and I said you don't have to tell
me twice because it just seemed so nice
and I was in Venice and I was living
with a model she had a parakeet
beautiful situation
yeah and then I did old school in it and
it was funny because we the the part I
had I was somebody they kidnapped Will
Farrell jumped out of a van it's the
Metallica scene is it when they're
playing master puppets it's not you they
go yeah yes and um uh so we were called
the pledges and the other pledges were
Simon Helberg who became a big star with
big bang and he does movies Rob cordray
who who became a [ __ ] uh you know he
does tons of movies and uh he was on com
uh what was that Show with Jon Stewart
[ __ ] it's still going Daily Show Daily
Show Rob became a correspondent and got
big and met them movies
um me cordry Simon hillberg this guy
Rick Gonzalez who does a lot of [ __ ]
really good dude and um anyway it was
really cool
um they cut a bunch of our stuff out so
we were kind of glorified extras but it
was a great experience like I got to see
because we were in so many scenes I was
filming a lot and just watching Will
Ferrell work
you know doing his comedy I hate to
watch Will Ferrell work yeah I mean I
was right there you know when I got to
see him like do his thing up close
it's amazing yeah it's an I mean it's an
iconic [ __ ] comedy film I still get
good residual I wanted to ask you
without without let me tell you
something because it's it's picked up
everywhere it's on everywhere explain a
lot yeah and people are emailing me
going I didn't know you were in this
movie because you still get good
residuals that you know good because it
was how many years ago yeah [ __ ]
movie it was like 20 22 000. yeah it was
it was a while ago and uh I the first
residual check I got they they're big
when they start and then they they they
Peter out right the first residual I got
was a check for 17 grand God
and I was like I thought I was rich hell
yeah yeah I was I was like baby we have
no worries
of course it was gone pretty quickly but
I was like it's over baby the struggle
is over
uh all right we gotta get you out of
here I gotta get out of here but I have
a question to ask you your first time
here I was I gave you a heads up before
now after what we've talked about you're
growing up your parents your anxieties
panic attacks what advice would you give
to 16 year old Eddie pepitone
oh okay
I okay my advice to the 16 year old me
would be don't
put so much pressure on yourself and
live your life
like don't try to live your father's
life because he's [ __ ] nuts and he's
trying to live through you because he
doesn't have a life you have to do your
own thing and and basically I would say
say to the 1600 you're gonna be all
right
because I never thought I would be all
right because I was always so [ __ ]
[ __ ] anxious you know it's like
you're gonna be all right just do your
own thing you know follow your own
[ __ ] path instead of trying to lift
someone else's path
because if you follow your own path and
you follow your your your passion you
know what you want to do it will work
out it will now in today's America
that's no longer true
because it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
that's great that's great thank you so
much for coming on again please plug and
promote everything the thing I forgot to
plug up top is my podcast uh apocalypse
soon
apocalypse
which is again about the deterioration
of everything in America and the world
but apocalypse soon it's on all things
comedy it's where you get all your
podcasts I also put it up on YouTube
uh so please check that out all right
man thank you so much Eddie prepaton
thank you um and as always
ryansickler.com Ryan sickler on all
social media we will talk to you all
next week
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]